it's been over two years since the
country splits 5248
leave remain the nationwide referendum
result
was perfectly mirrored in the hampshire
town of beijingstoke
so a good place to test whether there's
been the brexit backlash
suggested by a landmark sky data poll
which shows
half of people now in favour of a new
referendum
between no deal the czechos deal and no
brexit with 40 percent against
on first preferences 48 percent would
vote to stay
in the eu 27 percent for a no deal
brexit
and just 13 percent backing the
government's chequers deal
so after second preferences the polls
suggest 59
would opt to stay in the eu and 41
percent
would go for a no deal a leading
remainer campaigner
claims this shows brexit will now go to
a second referendum
if public opinion continues to shift as
the sky
poll has indicated now it is doing
everyone will have to get ready for a
people's vote on the final deal
no way say number 10 the verdict of
referendum night remains
there will not be a second referendum
under any circumstances
but one vote leave campaign hq staffer
the pro-single market liberal leaver
oliver norgrove said no deal fears were
making even him waver
no deal and remain are the front-running
candidates at the moment in terms of the
outcome of brexit
uh and if there was no deal versus
remain uh it's a difficult question like
i i don't have a concrete answer for you
because i as i say
it's likely that i would abstain in that
circumstances but i think for me a no
deal is
suicide i think it's self-harm on an
immeasurable scale
around basingstoke there are staunch
levers who now share this
unease but also remainers who don't back
a second referendum
nobody can decide what's going on we're
left in the nurse we don't know anything
it just seems like we're chasing our
tails yeah you're surprised if there was
another referendum
because the government i would i would
like you'd like another offender yeah
you know like all of these people you've
got no reassurance to many of the toy
parties but no reassurance
every flavor of opinion but here like in
the country at large
you do struggle to find people who say
brexit is going well the new sky data
poll
has found that just 10 percent of people
think the government is doing a good job
negotiating brexit
78 say a bad job that's a 23 point drop
since we last asked the question in
march there's no question
whatsoever of any other referendum on
this we've had the one and only
referendum we need the decision of the
british people
is clear and the government's now
getting on with the job a lack of public
backing for the chequers compromise
won't just make it harder for the prime
minister to get the eu to meet that
compromise as she desperately needs
with remainers seeing fears over a no
deal as a route to another referendum
and brexiters seeing the chequers
compromise
as a betrayal of brexit the prime
minister
is seeing the middle ground disappear
from beneath her feet
at carlton gardens the removal vans have
finally arrived
three weeks after boris johnson quit as
foreign secretary
over the chequers plan here at least
albeit
after interim period leave means leave
what it means across the country is now
firmly back up for grabs
faisal islam sky news